we gotta get booked for like a morning
talk show and pitch us like not at all
who we are yeah two impressionist
comedians they've toured Asia for
various puppeteering and and
impressionist acts and we get up there
to we talk for a minute like wow they're
really bad information did you do
something for us and rose up they're
like Who am I what are doing this
together yeah you might recognize this
guy
hello I am Arnold pumping the iron who's
that I was like correct I don't know
Billy Bob Thornton you're right classic
sign of a bad impression is when you
have to tell the person who you are
I recognize this one
my name is Scarlett Johansson and I'm in
various movies such as Marvel titles Wow
Wow that one was good I really want us
to get booked for his shitty morning
talk show and you ruin it yeah like
commit to the bit like we did at the
streamys but something paint even more
painful when we get there yeah but like
in the green room and [ __ ] were really
like yeah yeah yeah totally I was never
a super normal yeah yeah completely when
the camera turns on we're here with Cody
Cohen well Miller I'm Stewie Stewie
Griffin actually well he really sounds
like Stewie Stewie Griffin can't believe
he's going to do this for the whole show
they're like we're not doing anything
and myself I'm not doing anything either
I'm Arnold - now he's mean on him we are
annulled together you don't even
[Laughter]
back to Stewie Oh where's the fat man
see I [ __ ] hate people morning talk
shows I just really they deserve it I
feel like they deserve getting [ __ ]
with yeah especially those two [ __ ]
wine moms that always have terrible
opinions like Bradley Jackson breath
yeah [ __ ] whatever those stupid names
are Kathie Lee and Hoda yeah what are
they on there they're on ambien ativan
they're on various [ __ ] substances
but all they do is get wasted on morning
TV and get and act like [ __ ] oh they
actually drink in the morning I mean I
don't know if they ever show it but they
seem like they're [ __ ] wasted every
time play clever go to YouTube
Kathleen Hoda Kathleen and Hoda Kathie
Lee Jota is a weird society and author
of Jack and the geniuses a genius
himself mr. Bill Nye every science
interaction let's see all right okay
we've got some big Bill Nye fans out
here what's your name Antoinette there
big Bill Nye these are these Bill Nyes
groupies yeah eight it's like eight like
[ __ ] just supermodels yeah we're big
yeah yeah you know they uh they just
don't they you know who Candace she's a
firecracker yeah she's uh you know I
tried to I try to let her off easy but
she can't give enough for the bill she
can't get enough knowledge if you know
what I mean always looking for more
we have we have great chemistry when we
get to mixin it's dynamite let's play
South Jersey just what what you a pot
what would it take to be a big Bill Nye
fan the largest snowflake on record had
a reported diameter of wait are these
are these snowflake diameters or Bill's
dick size because if so see if it's the
latter see I just I went to [ __ ]
largest snowflake on record I don't know
if the libs have a big enough measuring
tape yeah yeah d blue haired girls ding
bills is 15 inches wide this is sequoia
tree is so ridiculous okay okay okay I
don't know if you heard of the first
time where she won the [ __ ] book
anyways bro she won Hoda's book
oh that's wack but she's a big Bill Nye
fan yeah so condescending dude we got
something big bill and I fans here all
right so this is big bill night question
for my book and she gets [ __ ] stoked
because she got a hole yeah you better
be a big Hoda fan 15 inches in Montana
someplace in the 1870s Ohno I measured
it against my massive massive lung my
massive Bill Nye car yeah would be a big
snowflake this [ __ ] sucks dude who
would ever watch this
it's
you saw that you saw her visibly get
tired look at this look at this look at
this she doesn't like that he's talking
oh my god
repeats repeats repeats and gets bigger
oh my god this sucks dude don't
disrespect the bill you're gonna win I
feel lucky for you alright ready when
you drop you see her son in the back got
no lips and that smile what's happening
there's a line as a cartoon when you
drop this item into a glass of freshly
poured champagne it will bounce up and
down continuously you you [ __ ] should
know this cuz you always drinking yeah
is it a raisin a peanut or a carrot ask
your son be that guy's on the horn with
that he can't wait [ __ ] you
wrong is cuz there's s bills shooter
right there oh yeah you know you saw
them being dicks they are you don't want
to play games yeah exactly be shut the
[ __ ] up
is it a weed a book read a book you're
dumb [ __ ] science I don't want this
[ __ ] trash book so the answer is
raisins I can't see I can't see him get
disrespected it's do one more alright
yeah yeah
you